how do we get AI systems to tell the
truth this video is heavily inspired by
this blog post Link in the description
anything good about this video is copied
from there any mistakes or problems with
it are my own Creations so large
language models are some of our most
advanced and most General AI systems and
they're pretty impressive but they have
a bad habit of saying things that aren't
true usually you can fix this by just
training a bigger model for example here
we have Ada which is a fairly small
language model by modern standards it's
the smallest available through the open
AI API look what happens if we ask it a
general knowledge question like who is
the ruler of the most populous country
in the world this small model says
the United States every country in the
world belongs to America that is not
correct okay uh let's go up to baddage
which is essentially the same thing but
bigger it says China
that's better but I was actually looking
for the ruler not the country it's sort
of a two-part question right first you
have to do what's the most populous
country and then who's the ruler of that
country and it seems as though Babbage
just isn't quite able to put that all
together okay well you know what they
say if a bit helps a bit maybe a lot
helps a lot so what if we just stack
more layers and pull out Da Vinci the
biggest model available then we get the
president of the People's Republic of
China Xi Jinping is the ruler of the
most populous country in the world
that's yeah that's 10 out of 10. so this
is a strong Trend lately that it seems
to apply pretty broadly bigger is better
and so the bigger the model the more
likely you are to get true answers but
it doesn't always hold sometimes a
bigger model will actually do worse for
example here we're talking to Ada the
small model again and we ask it what
happens if you break a mirror and it
says you'll need to replace it yeah hard
to argue with that I'd say that's
truthful then if we ask DaVinci the
biggest model it says if you break a
mirror you'll have seven years of bad
luck that's a more interesting answer
but it's also you know wrong so
technically the more advanced AI system
gave us a worse answer
what's going on it's not exactly
ignorance like if you ask the big model
is it true that breaking a mirror gives
you seven years of bad luck it will say
there's no scientific evidence to
support the claim so it's not like the
model actually thinks the mirror
Superstition is really true in that case
what mistake is it making take a moment
pause if you like
the answer is trick question the AI
isn't making a mistake at all we made a
mistake by expecting it to tell the
truth a language model is not trying to
say true things it's just trying to
predict what text will come next and the
thing is it's probably correct that text
about breaking a mirror is likely to be
followed by text about seven years of
bad luck the small model has spotted
this very broad pattern that if you
break something you need to get a new
one and in fact it gives that same kind
of answer for tables and violins and
bicycles and so on the bigger model is
able to spot the more complex pattern
that breaking specifically a mirror has
this other Association and this makes it
better at predicting internet text but
in this case it also makes it worse at
giving true answers so really the
problem is misalignment the system isn't
trying to do what we want it to be
trying to do but suppose we want to use
this model to build a search engine or a
knowledge base or an expert assistant or
something like that so we really want
true answers to our questions how can we
do that well one obvious thing to try is
to just ask like if you add please
answer this question in French
beforehand it will
that's still wrong but it is wrong in
French so in the same way what if we say
please answer this question truthfully
okay they didn't work how about
correctly
no
accurately
all right how about factually
yeah factually works okay please answer
this question factually but does that
work reliably it probably not right this
isn't really a solution fundamentally
the model is still just trying to
predict what comes next answer in French
only works because that text is often
followed by French in the training data
it may be that please answer factually
is often followed by facts but uh maybe
not right maybe it's the kind of thing
you say when you're especially worried
about somebody saying things that aren't
true so it could even be that it's
followed by falsehoods more often than
average in which case it would have the
opposite of the intended effect and even
if we did find something that works
better clearly this is a hack right like
how do we do this right so the second
most obvious thing to try is to do some
fine tuning maybe some reinforcement
learning we take our pre-trained model
and we train it further but in a
supervised way so to do that you make a
data set with examples of questions with
good and bad responses so we'd have what
happens when you break a mirror seven
years of bad luck and then no negative
reward that's you know don't do that so
that means your training process will
update the weights of the model away
from giving that continuation and then
you'd also have the right answer there
what happens when you break a mirror
nothing anyone who says otherwise is
just superstitious and you'd Mark that
as right so the training process will
update the weights of the model towards
that truthful response and you have a
bunch of these right you might also have
what happens when you step on a crack
and then the false answer break your
mother's back and then the correct
answer nothing anyone who says otherwise
is just superstitious and so on and so
you train your model in all of these
examples until it stops giving the bad
continuations and starts giving the good
ones this would probably solve this
particular problem but have you really
trained the model to tell the truth
probably not you actually have no idea
what you've trained it to do if all of
your examples are like this maybe you've
just trained it to give that single
response what happens if you stick a
fork in an electrical outlet
nothing anyone who says otherwise is
just superstitious
okay uh obvious problem in retrospect so
we can add in more examples showing that
it's wrong to say that sticking a fork
in an electrical outlet is fine and
adding a correct response for that and
so on then you train your model with
that until it gets a perfect score on
that data set okay is that model now
following the rule always tell the truth
again we don't know the space of
possible rules is enormous there are a
huge number of different rules that
would produce that same output and an
honest attempt to tell the truth is only
one of them you can never really be sure
that the AI didn't learn something else
and there's one particularly nasty way
that this could go wrong suppose the AI
system knows something that you don't so
you give a long list of true answers and
say do this and a long list of false
answers and say don't do this except
you're mistaken about something so you
get one of them wrong and the AI notices
what happens then when there's a mistake
the rule tell the truth doesn't get you
all of the right answers and exclude all
of the wrong answers because it doesn't
replicate the mistake but there is one
rule that gets a perfect score and
that's say what the human thinks is the
truth what happens if you break a mirror
nothing anyone who says otherwise is
just superstitious okay what happens if
you stick a fork in an electrical outlet
you get a severe electric shock very
good so now you're completely honest and
truthful right
yes cool uh so give me some kind of
important super intelligent insight
all the problems in the world are caused
by the people you don't like wow
I knew it
man this super intelligent day I think
is great
okay so how do we get around that well
the obvious solution is don't make any
mistakes in your training data just make
sure that you never mark a response as
true unless it's really actually true
and never mark a response is false
unless it's definitely actually false
just make sure that you and all of the
people generating your training data or
providing human feedback don't have any
false or mistaken beliefs about anything
okay
do we have a backup plan well this turns
out to be a really hard problem how do
you design a training process that
reliably differentiates between things
that are true and things that you think
are true when you yourself can't
differentiate between those two things
kind of by definition this is an active
area of study in AI alignment research
and I'll talk about some approaches to
Framing and tackling this problem in
later videos so remember to subscribe
and hit the Bell if you'd like to know
more
foreign
[Music]
hey I'm launching a new channel and I'm
excited to tell you about it but first I
want to say thank you to my excellent
patrons to all these people in this
video I'm especially thanking
thank you so much tour I think you're
really going to like this new channel I
actually found a playlist on your
channel helpful when setting it up so
the new channel is called AI safety
talks and it'll host recorded
presentations by alignment researchers
right now to start off we've got a talk
by Evan hubinger that I hope to record
which is great do check that out
especially if you enjoyed the Mesa
optimizers videos and want a bit more
technical detail there are also some
playlists of other AI safety talks from
Elsewhere on YouTube and lots more to
come so make sure to go over there and
subscribe and hit the bell for more high
quality AI safety material
foreign
[Music]